المشاهدينها الكرام منذ صباح الخميس
السادس والعشرين من الشهر الحالي حيث
اقتحمت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه مخيمه جنين
شماليه الضفه الغربيه المحتله وانطلقت
شراره هذه الازمه التي نعيشها الان
المنطقه الشماليه في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله كانت عنوان هذه العمليات حيث
استهدفت قوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه مجموعه
من المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جينيا كما
تقول القوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين
هناك مجموعات عسكريه فلسطينيه تحاول تنفيذ
عمليات او نفذت عمليات كما تقول القوات
الاسرائيليه وان هذه القوات او هذه
المجموعات الفلسطينيه تحاول تنفيذ عمليات
داخل العمق الاسرائيلي كما تدعي قوات
الاحتلال مجموعه من المقاومه اكتشفت تسلل
القوات الاسرائيليه الى هذه المنطقه
واشتبكت معها في مخيم جنين هذه هي العمليه
ادت الى سقوط تسعه شهداء في العمليه بعد
ساعات قليله
من هذه العمليه انطلقت صواريخ او انطلق
صاروخان تحديدا من قطاع غزه باتجاه المدن
والبلدات الاسرائيليه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي في نفس الليله
قصف مواقع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع
غزه ولكن اللافته ان كتائب القسام قالت
بانها تصدت الطائرات الحربيه باسلحه مضاده
للطائرات بعد 24 ساعه من هذا التطور وصل
الشاب خيري همم علقم وصل من منزله في
مدينه في حي الطور شرقي المسجد الاقصى
المبارك كما شاهد على الشاشه انتقل
بسيارته الى حي او بلده بيت حنينه شماليه
المدينه المقدسه ودخل من هنا الى الحي
الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي نبيه يعقوب وهناك
اطلق النار على مجموعه من المستوطنين وقتل
سبعه منهم قبل ان يشترك مع الشرطي
الاسرائيلي ويستشهد في المكان عند مدخل
همم نبي يعقوب بين نبي كوب وبيتحنينا
ساعات بعد تلك العمليه وفي مدينه القدس
المحتله ايضا ولكن نحو المنطقه الجنوبيه
هذا هو المسجد الاقصى المبارك حيسلوان او
بلده سلوان حيث نفذت عمليه همم مسلحه هناك
اطلاق نار الفتى الفلسطيني محمد عليوات
الذي اطلق النار واصاب اثنين قبل ان يطلق
عليه جندي اسرائيلي نار ويصيبه في المكان
وتعتقله الاحتلال العيون الان تتجه نحو
المنطقه الشماليه لانه القوات الاسرائيليه
والجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لما اراده في
العمليه وفقا محللين عسكريين والسياسيين
فانه سيستهدف بدرجه اساسيه اما منطقه جنين
ومخيمها كما ذكرنا لانه هناك مجموعه من
المسلحين الفلسطينيين تتحصن في مخيم جنين
او انه سيستهدف نابلس والبلده القديمه حيث
تتحسن مجموعه اخرى من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين المجموعات المسلحه الموجوده
في المنطقه الشماليه هي
مجموعه من المس التابعين لفصائل فلسطينيه
كما نشاهد في الصوره هذه الصوره من مخيم
جنين مقادم كتائب شهداء الاقصى التابع
لحركه فتح مقاتل من كتيبه جينيا الجناح
المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ومقاتل من
كتائب القسام الجناح المسلح بحركه حماس في
صوره واحده في مخيم جنين هؤلاء هدف للقوات
الاسرائيليه ولكن هناك هدف اخر ايضا وهم
مجموعه عرين الاسود المتواجدين في البلده
القديمه من مدينه نابلس والذين ينفدون
عمليات كما تقول القوات الاسرائيليه علينا
الاسود لا ينتمون لاي فصيل من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وتمكن القوات الاحتلال من قتل
العدد من قادتها لكن المجموعه تؤكد مواصله
القتال وتنفيذ عمليات اطلاق نار على اهداف
اسرائيليه في المنطقه هذه الت